yes when we had technology and this AI available to us
of course it is very interesting to write application
and one thing I found myself doing is
I found myself writing almost like 7 to 8 application on the go
but again I kept on asking myself okay
is this something I can do
but in real sense it seems as though I can
so what I did was I had subscriptions to Cloudy Eye
and at first I was using their Pro version
and soon I realized that I was born in more AI token
so before you know I upgraded to their max plan
of course with that I had 20% more AI token to use
so I can build multiple application on the go
so I started spinning up multiple applications
I had multiple projects going on
I just have some level of parameters to make some of those things work
not quite long I realized that I was just dancing around the circle
yes
I have AI to ready to turn out a lot of resources within few seconds
but here I am working on multiple projects at the same time
with powerful machines
there are multiple research being done with developers
one with Ava Business Review
that really shows that developers and technology enthusiasts
or technology professionals are really burning out
as a result of all of this technology
one of the greatest skill that is essential to every developer
is your ability to be able to know when this burnout is taking place
and taking the right step
to ensure that you come out with the results that is required
this case may be something that you also are going through
yes the fact that we have all of these tools accessible to us
does not really mean that
these things are really helping us to be productive
but hey at the end of the day
we have to use these tools
but you know what we just need to use it intelligently
in such a way that
we are not just carried away by the magnificent of the technology
while losing the actual essence of productivity